olá eu sou a maria luiza e hoje vim
apresentar meu trabalho que é desgaste
mental e poluições degradação ambiental
degradar é devastar e destruir o meio
ambiente
existem três tipos de dizer a degradação
do meio ambiente de matar mento
queimadas ea poluição desmatamento
desmatamento é feita pela atividade
humana que eles cortam massa de floresta
para indústria da madeira para fazer
diversas coisas como cadeiras mesas
armários porta aquelas que desarmar os
porta-copos e exceto quem manda
as queimadas também e feita pela
atividade humana que lhes coloco jogam
fogo na natureza para fazer a atividade
agrícola para deixar o solo lisinho e se
não faz não é bom pessoal porque israel
não está preparado e causa erosão mas
também não é só por causa disso também
não é certo você matar o jogo fogo numa
árvore que doeu 50 anos e você vai lá
jogar fogo poluição eu essa imagem da
punição porque eles são diversos tipos
de poluição
essa é a poluição do ar essa é a
poluição do solo essa é a poluição
sonora essa poluição visual que essa é a
poluição da água poluição é a
contaminação ou degradação do meio
ambiente que direta e indiretamente pode
ser pode ser perder pode prejudicar a
saúde eo bem estar da população
podemos identificar diversos tipos de
poluição
a poluição sonora poluição visual
poluição atmosférica posição da água e
luz são gonçalo e começar um negócio
que é a posição que eu vou me aprofundar
mais a posição minusa por causa da
poluição luminosa
a gente não pode ver as estrelas no céu
porque o excesso de luz na cidade
reflete no céu e aí não dá pra ver as
estrelas mas a poluição luminosa não só
atrapalha e observação das estrelas como
também atrapalha os animais como por
exemplo dar uga uga de couro com ela
nasce ela sempre segue a sistemas para o
caminho do oceano mas com a poluição
luminosa é muita luz
mas tanta luz que ofusca a visão dela
que ela vai lado oposto o posto
o posto e vai pro nosso continente que
aí pode ser que ela é tão pequenininho
que para algumas áreas maiores pode como
ela ela pode faltar de desidratação e
também ser atropelada por carros também
a poluição luminosa atrapalha as aves
porque as aves americanas elas
elas viajam à noite e assim as rosas ela
se milhão antes e produzem ande e aí até
para todo o ecossistema também em 1994
houve um apagão em los angeles 6.7 que
por conta da poluição luminosa porque
eles viram uma das estrelas que era via
láctea que ele estava vendo pela
primeira vez e por conta da via latika é
de lá que é ele não sabia que era a via
láctea e acharam que por conta daquilo
que eles não sabiam que era carlos lopes
é causou apagão eles acharam que era uma
nave alienígena mas não era a primeira
vez que ele estava vendo a via láctea
muito obrigada